party on dudes so we have a teaser
trailer our first trailer for Bill and
Ted faced the music which was one of my
anticipated movies of 2020 though I
remain cautiously optimistic also in
terms of my anticipated movies for 2020
I have a feeling three of them actually
might come out and judging by the
trailer it might be Bill and Ted it's
coming out in 2020 sometime undisclosed
date just 2020 in general it's not like
tenets or tenets like we will Bill and
Ted's like 2020 we hope but in the
trailer for Bill and Ted faced the music
villain Ted they're being lectured by
this council from the future
sadly the late great George Carlin and I
cannot stress great enough he won't be
in it he has passed he's no longer with
us so I feel like we're gonna feel that
loss not that we don't already feel the
loss I feel like the world needs George
Carlin now more than ever but he lives
on in his comedy which are very
applicable lesson nonetheless this
counsel from the future is like 25 years
ago you played a concert in front of the
whole world and now you're playing in a
bar in Barstow California in front of 40
people most of whom were there for $2
taco night yeah things have not worked
out as planned for the great bill S
Preston Esquire and Ted Theodore Logan
love his hair though so apparently the
trailer tells us they've been trying to
write this song that's gonna save the
future for all these years writer's
block they haven't been able to write it
so they get this idea to go to the
feature and steal the song from
themselves after they've written it
either they go to this doom and gloom
future and which them in the future
they're still going to write the song
with her all jacked up in prison I
laughed for a solid minute I have to eat
in the trailer oh my god how did you
like our song it's a little on the dark
side but you know that's cool so either
that's just part of fate playing itself
out or they go to an alternate future an
alternate future where they haven't
written a song it's again it's like Back
to the Future 2 I keep bringing this up
and I talk about alternate timelines but
it's so perfectly illustrated in that
movie if they were supposed to write the
song and they haven't written a song
that means they're in an alternate
reality in which if they go to the
future it's the future of this alternate
reality where the song doesn't exist the
same reason Marty and Doc couldn't just
go to the future and stop Marty from
buying the Almanac it would be the
alternate future of this alternate
timeline to which I have to assume the
only way to fix everything is to go to
the past so are they going to go to the
asked our future Bill and Ted gonna
lecture past villain Ted so I don't know
but this teaser trailer really dug and
it showed me just enough that's all I
need to know about the movies the
general plot like okay they want to
steal the music from themselves great
have this be the only trailer you
release I mean in terms of marketing as
the movies closer to it's unknown
release date you have to show more
trailers sure but I don't have to know
any more than this just make them like
TV spots that are really vague this is
all I want to know about the movie I
just have to know the movies coming out
yeah remind the audience with new
trailers that is coming out but don't
show any more than this this trailer
actually got me excited for this movie
that I'm still I'm looking forward to
but I'm cautiously optimistic just
because Hollywood has a tendency to I
don't know what's the phrase [ __ ] [ __ ]
up when they make a sequel decades after
the last movie but the premise looks
funny it looks like Bill and Ted still
maintain the spirit of Bill and Ted also
you see death in it and who looks like
they're straight up in hell maybe that's
a future where they didn't write the
music it's so far in the future that
it's like yeah hell on earth death
destruction and deaths just having a
good time so yeah the trailer for Bill
and Ted faced the music I thought it was
a solid teaser trailer all right so the
trailer for Bill and Ted faced the music
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
and always remember be excellent to each
other and party on dudes
[Music]